are you ready for this what the hell am
I doing here I'm not the guy for this
holy crap my water just broke nope yeah
that's what do you say there's a brand
new batch of TV shows headed our way
this fall but which ones deserve a spot
in your DVR we at et are revealing the
top six shows of the season on our 2016
once to watch list first up is ABC's
gripping drama designated survivor
capitals been attacked eagle is gone sir
you are now the president of the United
States Kiefer Sutherland stuns as a
lowly cabinet member who unexpectedly
becomes the president after a
catastrophic terrorist attack during the
State of the Union address do you really
really Russia step down I do you may be
right but for now I'm all you got in
Fox's pitch scene stealer kylie bunbury
takes the field in this inspiring drama
as the first female pitcher in Major
League Baseball [ __ ] and moan all you
want gentlemen but tonight a girl's
gonna be the lead sports story in the
world NCIS favorite Michael Weatherly
returns to CBS and bull the cheeky
courtroom drama inspired by before the
career of dr. Phil McGraw dr. bull knows
how they'll vote even before they do
next is this is US embassies family
drama D that will instantly tug on your
heartstrings this is the biggest moment
of your life
which one I'm just pregnant Mandy Moore
Milo Ventimiglia and sterling k brown
shine as characters whose lives
intertwined in curious ways and Jill
fall head-over-heels in love once you
discover the series big twist go see you
babies they're excited to meet their
father and the CW is the only network
with two shows on our list the quirky
rom-com no tomorrow and D compelling
drama frequency in no tomorrow Evie
meets a man of her dreams long sigh via
but there's just one earth shattering
problem human condo has eight months and
12 days left on a half you're serious
yeah yeah the apocalypse is done no and
in frequency based on the film of the
same name Peyton lyst stars as rainy
Sullivan an ordinary girl who discovers
an extraordinary connection to her late
father
what's your name right Sullivan dad
there you have it those are each ease
top TV picks for fall 2016 tweet me your
ones to watch and keep it locked to et
online for all the biggest news on your
small screen favorites